yo what's up everybody
we're live once again on a saturday
morning here in los angeles
thank you for joining the stream i hope
you guys are ready to learn i hope you
guys are
feeling okay um hope everyone's doing
all right
on this weekend yeah it's good to be
back i'm excited for this one
so um just as a as a quick overview what
we're going to be doing today
basically i want to recreate a photo
that's kind of my thing i i love
photography
i love doing um 3d art and when i can't
go out and i can't travel
and take all the film photography that i
love doing i like to
you know keep that same style and that
vibe here in 3d so i'm going to be
recreating a photo
in 3d and let me pull up that photo for
you guys
god dang these cats dude these cats
all right let's see
let's get this photo pulled up you guys
saw it isn't the thumbnail
let's load this in
all right so i'm using pure ref to
reference these photos
and this is what we're going to recreate
i've already done a little bit of the
work here
um doing some of the modeling of the
the the street lamp and whatnot and
we're going to be talking about how to
do these wires and lay out these wires
there's a lot of different ways to do
that
but we want to bring it to this final
point by the end of the stream
and i'm going to give myself two hours
to do this because
honestly guys well there's a couple
announcements actually this leads me
into the announcements
um so i've talked about doing an hdri
cut like a custom hdri tutorial for a
long time
and i think it's actually time that this
thing comes out and it's going to come
out
on tuesday and today
is basically the the last of my time to
finish
that tutorial so i'm going to be sitting
in this chair for the next freaking
12 hours so i just want to make sure i
get enough work done on the hdri
tutorial so i'm giving myself
two hours on this to get a really nice
look and a nice
final image um also as as another
announcement
i'm actually speaking um
on maxon uh maxon is holding basically
like a
an event on c graph and i'm gonna be
speaking about how to
do like a complete workflow when you're
trying to put in your like 3d
objects into your live action footage
let me actually show you guys
if you go to maxon.net
it's the front page right here the the
3d and motion design show
see graph edition so my my uh
my class my presentation is actually i
think the first one up on tuesday
let's let's find out more you guys
definitely need to show up to that it's
going to be really fun and there's going
to be a live q a
right after the fact so let's see if we
can't find
the overview um no is this not what we
want
max on 3d how do you go to the say i
should know this
find out more she'll be here
here we go 3dmotionshow.com
9 a.m pacific standard time
is my class okay so i'm yeah it looks
like max on news and amounts
announcements at 8 30 and right at 9 a.m
the secret to photo real visual effects
with me at 9am so i will see you guys
there that's tuesday
lots going on this week um
so let's just jump into this and
and start figuring this thing out
so thank you guys thank you guys for
joining it's good to see everybody in
here
who's in here actually before we hop in
christian what's going on
good to see you any familiar faces i saw
brett was in the stream last week but i
missed him
i don't want to miss him again
welcome welcome everybody a lot of
familiar faces
awesome sweet so i'll try and check the
chat
um you know as i can as we as we
power through this um
scoring thank you for the super chat
he says uh camera must be a saint
letting uh letting me stream every
single week
i know mine is for letting me use all my
saturday evenings
uh for watching stuff so thank you
enjoy your sandwich i love you
all right let's jump in
so the challenge here definitely is
these wires there's a lot of like
little details in here as far as like
these little
rivets and bits and whatnot that we need
to get into just a little bit
um but there's a lot of tiny pieces that
need to be modeled but these are pretty
simple they're just kind of like
rectangles and cubes
beveled out so we can spend maybe
20 minutes working on the modeling that
needs
you know like the remainder of the
modeling that needs to be done
reuben appreciate you sir thank you
thank you so much
i don't know what that says other than
yes
and maybe you agree or something like
that
but thank you sir um you guys are
awesome so
yeah let's spend the next 20 minutes
just talking about modeling out these
little modules and stuff
and how you can quickly do that in c4d
and
you know there's already one like these
ones i already have modeled
like up here you guys can see i have
this kind of modeled out it's very
basic modeling you know and i do go over
a lot of this
in my c-graph presentation too we model
a newspaper stand which
actually was one of the one of the
streams here
and there's another little module here
that i just put together before the
stream
and it's just a very basic you know
cylindrical object
beveled out extruded out and all that
good stuff
oh is there a raw photo download link um
let me see if i can upload it to the
discord server really quick
so that you guys can follow along
um let's see
all right so if you guys go to the
discord server the link is right down in
the description
i'll drop it into general
general chat okay
and let me just let me just drag that in
real quick
let's see
so you guys can follow along with me
oh god okay it's a hundred megabytes
wait no it's not it's 24 megabytes
i'm going to drag in the janky phone
picture that i took you guys can get the
same vibe it's
this one right here i actually like
this look a little bit better
um so this will be like the lighting i'm
going for
i like the lens flare and everything but
you know this picture here is just
a little larger for zooming in and
getting that detail i can upload the
picture
a little later once the stream is over
but um yeah let's let's take like 15 20
minutes and just model out some of these
little modules that we can copy and
paste
throughout all of this you know the
detail really counts when you're
trying to recreate a photo and match it
perfectly
in cg all of the little details really
count
in every step so especially with
modeling you know you want to model
all the details and get all that good
stuff in there
so that's exactly what we're gonna do
i've said it enough let's just go for it
let's see if we can adjust this window
all right
sweet okay
why is it needs to be on top window
image
always on top sweet okay
all right let's start with like the
biggest little piece
right here this little box all right so
we'll just make a cube for that and i
always have a figure in my scene because
it helps me determine the scale of
things
and again we can always adjust the scale
later but it's nice to have
something in the beginning to help us to
like guide our
our modeling process
maybe something like that all right
and this looks very very straightforward
the only thing we want to do is make
sure we're beveling our edges all right
so i'm just going to
make this cube editable you can hit nb
to switch to wireframe mode
and it looks like it has like a little
door up here a little
access port so i'm just gonna
hit kl
and extrude some of these faces here one
two and
three i'm gonna hit d and just scale
that out
so why it does this i'm not really sure
but that needs to be
bridged so i'll do uh m b
in edge mode and just bridge those
there's probably a better way of doing
this and then md
will fill the polygon holes
or it should at least
i don't know why it why it isn't
maybe we undo that
um let's see
yeah i don't know why that's the case
there's probably some checkbox i need to
hit
weird i do not know why
hmm
so i wonder if there's some sort of
setting i probably just don't have
checked
there it is okay the maximum angle
polygons under maximum angle just needs
to be cranked up above 90
and that'll work properly
all right troubleshooting that is the
work of an effects artist this
troubleshooting all day
long let's give the back a little bit
more detail
so we'll come in here um
and hit ms
mw
i think that's like it's actually fine
how it is it looks like there's some
like
rivets here for wires to go into so we
can just
spawn some cylinders to bust those out
but before we do let's make sure all of
our stuff is beveled
beveling your your edges are going to
catch the light in a really nice way
and you're definitely going to want to
do that so i'm holding shift to give it
a bevel modifier
and we'll take that bevel offset down
really low to like .05
and we'll give it like
yeah something like that and holding
control
let's make a cylinder and that's going
to spawn the cylinder right in place
of that cube
and we want it to be plus x
and let's actually solo this i'm using
magic solo
very handy we'll scale that down
something like that let's come in here
and just make sure
we have a nice like filleted edge here
so i'm just going to check that box and
by default it actually looks
really nice and we can actually clone
this
so we'll start up here actually now
let's start down here
and i'm going to hold alt and clone
linearly
every inch every
every two uh every 1.5 inches
and we'll just drag the slider up and
there you go you got some
nice little circuit box we don't need to
worry about this side because you know
the angle of our image doesn't include
that side so you don't have to worry
about it
so i'll group these and just call this
circuit box
cool all right um so these rungs were
made from
um from like a spline and
a a like a circle spline basically and
that's
in a lathe
object here or in a sweep
rather and we'll be doing that for all
the wires and stuff
but let's figure out any other modules
we need to create so i have this one
here
made up and that's just copied and
pasted all around the model let's make
this box
here that's a cool looking piece
so let's try that okay let's spawn
a sphere i'm sorry a cube and we'll
scale it way down
and it looks like it's a little it's
like on the flat side
and a bit more rectangular like this
awesome uh sid dude
heck yeah man thanks for the super chat
appreciate you he says hey clint wanted
to thank you for these amazing live
streams i've learned a lot in the past
months thank you again buddy stay safe
you too sid i'm really glad you've
learned a lot
i'm glad that you guys are sticking
through this whole thing i know that
these can go pretty long but it really
does mean a lot you guys coming back
every single week
hanging out with me and learning
together that's
that's the whole thing man that's the
whole point learning and growing
together
i love it a lot and we keep each other
accountable right i know you guys keep
me accountable that's for sure
if it wasn't for you guys i wouldn't be
learning as much
because you know i'm forcing myself to
learn so that i can teach you guys all
the stuff
and hopefully we can all learn together
so it's been really cool
and like the weekly challenges have been
super fun
um and it's only gonna get better i
promise you it will only grow
into a stronger thing together
all right so let's create this little
module right
here it looks like
all right this is gonna be fun so
let's start with this like scaled down
this is like
this main piece across the top
um and reuben thanks for the super chat
yes i would come to houston for sure man
i would i'd travel anywhere i don't care
where it is um and i know jake is living
in texas if you guys are fans of
corridor and no jake he's he moved to uh
san antonio so
texas trips our uh are in our future
most definitely all right let's scale
these in uh mw
is extrude enter boom we'll
bevel it mt
or no is it m mt
no got my got my shortcuts mixed up
ms bevel ms so let's bevel it
out like this and adjust some of the
stuff we don't need all the subdivisions
um
i need to figure out how do i there it
is it's the offset
something like that so if you can see
a reference based off of this here it
might be a little intense
so we can uh
hit u y to grow our selection and we're
going to scale it
but if we scale it you can see how like
it actually scales up
this bit here we want this to remain
flat
so i'm just not going to scale it on the
y-axis
and i think that'll do it
yeah or wait yeah no that's good
so let's just scale it up a little bit
and then i'll scale it
boom right there okay and then it looks
like it's kind of getting inset so if we
set both of these
mw for extrude inner
and we'll bevel it again
so m
[Music]
s to bevel it down
and we'll work that offset again
let's try like point one
point two yeah something like that so
it's like a little it looks like a box
that holds a bunch of wires or something
now it has these screws on the side of
it
so what we could do is
chop it whoa okay
let's maybe go into side view here
and grab our knife tool
where are you knife tool we got to be in
edge mode for knife tool
line cut yeah we'll do a little line cut
i'm just going to hold shift
to make a a straight line
and we'll do it one more time holding
shift i'm hitting escape to get out of
the tool
and then once i have those lines cut all
right i'm going to make this little bit
here
i can select both of them and then just
move them around
so that they're kind of in the middle
and you can even scale them
like this so that we have
a little bit of room to add
another little bit here where our screw
is going to sit so i'm holding shift to
grab both of those edges
and um you know since this stream isn't
planned
a lot of stuff randomly comes to the top
of my head at random moments okay
um so i just want to note that like you
guys can do this in any program if
you're in blender or if you're in
maya or 3ds max or obviously i'm in c4d
whatever like you guys can this is all
basic this is stuff that translates
across
all 3d programs so don't
don't uh don't feel discouraged if you
are using blender
please follow along okay so we have our
base geometry here like that that works
for me we're gonna bevel these edges
that's
really gonna take this thing to the next
level is when we bevel the edges so
let's see here okay we could do this
probably i'm gonna use a couple bevel
modifiers so let's grab
some edges i think u b or no ul
is loop selection what about ring
selection
i thought it was ub yeah it is ub all
right
i'm going to deselect these inside edges
and i'm just want to select
the edges that are really going to be
beveled like
this here there's a big bevel this here
is a large bevel
and i'll save the rest for just a
smaller bevel so
with those selected i'm going to set the
selection
right we can always go select
and where is it set selection right
there
and i'll drop the bevel modifier on
there boom
and drop that selection tag we just made
in there so now it's only beveling those
little bits so
we do point one and like three and then
we can just take this
up so that actually works
point two or maybe maybe point one five
or something
oh uh if i'm saying your name right she
c c fam um you said super chat's not
available in vietnam
can you donate anywhere right now there
is not really a place
for that but i am releasing my first
digital prod um product my first digital
product
on tuesday with the hdri custom
tutorial so at the end of that video you
guys will be able to
purchase a an hdri pack that i put
together while making this tutorial
and it's actually themed around like
post apocalypse
battlefield style hdris so it's hdri is
taken from like inside of destroyed
helicopters or in tunnels or
crashed airplanes or um you know like
middle east kind of style
so i think i'm gonna sell it for like
eight bucks or something
that right now is probably the cheapest
way to donate
um if you cannot do a super chat here
otherwise i do sell photography the link
is in the description
and you actually get something physical
for your purchase
um they're all printed on super super
nice paper
uh it'll last through the ages and
everything
but okay enough enough marketing here
let's
let's get back to this module so we've
made that bevel modifier right
to get those edges the larger edges and
we can even make another one for these
these four to really make those let's
let's try it
so i'm going to deselect those two
deselect those two
let's set this selection so that's a new
one i'm going to control drag this bevel
drop our new selection in there okay and
let's actually go
back to our other modifier
deselect these edges and
update all right and let's just make
sure i think the hierarchy
matters not in this case okay
so let's turn them off and just focus
one at a time
all right so i'm just going to update
that selection there
and why is it not updating
let's try this let's try this one more
time all right so we have those bits
let's set that selection and we'll drop
that on there
cool going back in let's get
these guys
i think we're past our 15 20 minutes
already
but we still have a couple more things
all right um
let's set that selection let's make a
new bevel modifier holding shift
and we'll drop that selection on there
um let's see
why does why is it getting those edges
we don't want those edges
ah it's so much troubleshooting vfx is
so much
troubleshooting my goodness
let's maybe name this center
outside
this one will be our center
okay great this one will be
our outside okay so that's working i
just needed to get the naming
down so 0.3 and that's the reason we did
that
so we can bevel this edge even further
cool so now we have both of those
combined and now for a third one
we'll do another bevel modifier and
that's going to get everything
so we'll set it to point
well first let's make sure it looks
right okay so i'm going to just solo
that
and we'll do like .025
just like that so it's getting
everything and let's try turning on
our other modifiers and boom that looks
nice let's just make sure
this edge is all good
so we'll go like i don't know 0.25
and that geometry works so i go over
this
in my craft presentation as well how to
do the multiple bevel modifiers
on one object and it really really helps
out so now at this point i'm just going
to copy
some of the the nuts and bolts
right so let's go ahead and just control
drag the nuts and bolts
and i'm going to use the transfer tool
to transfer it
boom over to this object here
and they should be chilling yeah
right here okay so i'll take this
and we'll just
move it into place here okay
i'll use the axis center tool
and we'll get the axis right there in
the middle
boom perfect
and let's just rotate this thing 90
degrees holding shift it's going to snap
on those angles
and we'll scale it down oop make sure we
scale on y
and scale it down
so a lot of work a lot of detail work
goes into recreating a photo
like this so there's one there i'm going
to control drag to
to duplicate holding shift as well to
snap on those angles and we'll bring it
down here too
just like that all right so we have both
of those
we can control drag these
over to this side that's looking nice
um now it looks like there's these
bigger
little bolt sections here that we might
have to deal with a little later
but this definitely gets us
something here we can detail
to the end of time but we don't have all
the time in the world
let's um i might model these guys once
we lay the wires
that way we know how big to make them
um let's maybe try doing
like
this bit here that's holding the wires
to the actual pole okay
so let's group all this stuff first
i'll call this wire box
and we can leave it leave it where it is
for now
so we're building out all these pieces
right
so next let's do this little like
cylinder thing here how are we going to
make this it looks like it's
kind of hollow maybe we can make it from
a couple different parts
that might be the best way to do this
so i'm seeing a cylinder let's do
cylinder we can make it plus x
orientation right
scale it down
so they're pretty they're pretty small
it's probably something like this right
it looks like it's sticking out like
there
something like that okay
i'll give that 32 segments again we'll
hit nb for wireframe to see what's going
on
rotational segments we we can zero out
so let's make that editable so that's
like the base right here
it's very hard to see but that's the
base of this thing and then
this piece i think we can just create um
with some custom geometry so i'm holding
control
and i'm gonna spawn a cube and it'll
spawn it right in place
of that cylinder okay
so what i'm seeing here is something
[Music]
along
these lines like this
all right let's make that editable i'm
gonna hit
c alright now it looks like if i
if i make some cuts here in line mode
let's grab both of these little bits
here okay
i'm gonna hit d for extrude
and we'll extrude this out
and we'll move them down
and it looks like they're also scaled
down like this
and we want to orient
each one of these bits here we want to
do per object manipulation hopefully
this works
nope we've got to do it by one by one we
want to rotate this
90 degrees
and this other one by 90 degrees so that
we can just
extrude and touch down on that cylinder
so hitting d to extrude
to get to that cylinder
and it looks like we want to extrude one
more time
and scale them in but don't worry about
why we just want to scale them
in like this
and hitting i'm hitting s to snap my
viewport
to the object if it gets all off you're
like oh i can't find it you just hit
s and it'll it'll line up
cinema 4d will also orient around
anything that you have
that your mouse is hovering over so when
you're orienting around with your mouse
i'm holding alt
and clicking it's going to organize
around this bit if you want to orient
around
this cylinder you just hover your mouse
over that bit
scribble of life um scribble of life
i appreciate you man i'm glad i'm glad
you're enjoying this
okay so we want to scale
this sil or this cube a little bit so
i'm just gonna
let's see we want to scale it
on the x something like that
and you'll just set it in there and
we'll probably add a bolt
to fit right in there so let's go back
to that wire box grab one of those nuts
and bolts
ctrl drag and i'm going to use the
transfer tool
to transfer it boom yeah that that works
right here holding shift
90 degrees skill the crap out of this
thing make sure you're scaling on y so
it's hitting everything
and just sit it right in there and
that's going to look like a nice little
bolt
structure there the last thing we need
to do is bevel
our edges here and this technically i
feel like this needs
a cut it's not the best geometry
to be honest with you guys my modeling
skills are not the best i am
kind of just getting by just by cheating
so i'm gonna make a cut
um from here to here
i think
or maybe i don't know what the best way
to do this is
yeah let's go to point mode and let's go
to line cut let's go one there
one there same here
one there and one there
wait why did i make a cut there that
wasn't supposed to happen
oh oh it's cutting through everything
okay the line
tool is cutting through everything so we
have to make sure when we select the
line cut
you do re um
restrict to selection maybe
visible only that's what we want visible
only so we're going to go
inside to outside
inside to outside all right and then
let's bevel this thing so holding shift
will throw that bevel modifier in there
it's going to look like some
janky star wars aircraft but let's go
like point one 0.02
and let's crank up the angle threshold
ah man i might i might undo those lines
i made
technically the geometry isn't it's not
sound but
it's such a tiny piece
and it just feels better already
sweet hey
chris what's up dude what's up chris
if you guys don't know chris he runs
rocket lasso
and also does live streams i believe on
wednesday
he's the dynamic master so when it comes
to like
c4d physics and dynamics and
springs and connectors he is the guy
definitely check out his stuff um
good to have you man good to have you so
we're making uh
chris we're making this photo here and
for anyone else who just joined
we're recreating this photo and we're
modeling all these little tiny bits
um we should probably wrap that bit up
here
in the next five minutes or so we can
get so we can get to these wires
and i'm actually using a plug-in called
toppo wire
or topo wire i think topo wire is
probably how it's pronounced
and it's really cool it's actually
really easy to get
dynamic wires going but we might use a
combination of that and just
some straight up c4d splines because if
you look closely
these wires are following a very
specific path
and the top of wire is good for like a
ton of wires dynamic wires
that just need to be like fit into your
scene you don't have too much control
over
them but we're going to need to actually
control these wires so we're going to
come in here with splines and just kind
of like
you know mock this up
let's just wrap up this modeling section
here
um let's see okay we got this little guy
this connector guy
so let's go ahead and group all that
stuff together one
two three these guys boom we'll call
that
connector
sweet
and that'll be duplicated a few times um
all right anything else anything else
that like really needs to be done
modeling wise we got these main like
modules
here and here and i i think we're
good actually like that can just be
a rectangle or this little box
duplicated and as far as like
this stuff those are all just cubes you
know that's just cubes and cylinders
so let's set up our camera angle and
let's start
placing these objects and getting the
wires
correct all right because i think that
that's just definitely going to take a
minute getting these wires down so
let's let's get there alright so
i know for a fact
that i was on the ground when i took
this we are not
underneath the ground here so what i'm
gonna do is actually create a camera
all right um there's a little camera
button here
we can pilot the camera so we're inside
and let's put a constraint tag on it i'm
going to right click and go
uh where would it be rigging
uh protection a protection tag that's
totally gonna work for us and we're
locking things it's locking down
everything i can't move it
i can't rotate or anything so position
all right position
we want to lock just the y
axis the x and z we want to be able to
move around
okay and then the the rotation
we don't need to lock the rotation at
all
so this keeps the camera on the ground
right i can move basically any which way
i want
but i can't go underneath the ground
right that's
so that's really going to help us here
i'm zooming out and by zooming out i'm
walking backwards and i know i took this
on a 24 mil lens so i'm gonna go
24 and just
line it up here you know
so it's probably
now maybe maybe this is taller
all right let's try let's try 35 that
way our
our angle isn't as extreme but now i
feel like now we gotta go we gotta go 24
because
that's that's how the image was shot i
know it's also in two
three so we'll do uh uh what is it
900 by 600.
a 2 3 image and a pro tip for you guys
there's a photographer mark edward
harris he actually put together
um a photo book one of my favorite photo
books
it's called what is it the uh the way of
the japanese bath
absolutely incredible i put some of his
his images on my instagram
and i went to his class i went to one of
his classes at sami's camera
and he talked about um your portfolio as
a photographer and he said one of like
one of the most professional looking
aesthetically looking things you can do
when you're presenting your portfolio is
keep
your your aspect ratio for your photos
consistent they should be all the same
right so that's really why
on my instagram i try and
keep my aspect ratio the same i'll
either do 2 3 which
this camera here is a niker matt ftn
film camera
this camera will um take images at
a two three aspect ratio and you know i
just i just don't edit them
when i upload them upload them in their
native format same for
you know my uh
my a7 my a7r ii which i took this photo
on
so this is a um
it also takes photos into three so you
want to keep your aspect ratio
consistent
when you're putting together like your
photography portfolio
that's a good good tip from from mark
edward harris
check him out he's on instagram as well
okay um
let's get this module box up a little
higher the circuit box will move that
up something like there um
this where where are you okay
oh by the way ctrl shift z will undo
camera moves
this piece comes down to somewhere like
here
and i'm actually going to draw some
lines
just to have it i'm going to make a
cylinder
and let's put that cylinder let's see
here
let's put the cylinder on plus x
orientation
i am going to get the radius way down
and just make it really long
this is going to help us framing right
and then i'm going to hold ctrl
and go 90
with that i believe
that's how it's set up it might be
a bit harsher of an angle you know i
feel like it's a bit harsher of an angle
something like that and then
i'm willing to bet if i hold ctrl make
another one and we go 90
that these guys are going off into the
distance here
so i can move this like up
and that gives us just an idea of like
what our framing should look like imma
zoom in get a little closer
and somewhere along these lines here
i might i may have zoomed in i may not
have been at a full 24.
we can try 28.
remember which one we want to see the
back of this uh
of this circuit box not the direct side
but just like
the back side there so that kind of
gives us
we're getting these clues in our image
as to you know what's going on and also
this street light might be angled a bit
more towards the street so if i hop
out of the camera
and i'm just going to turn that off in
viewport we zoom in
let's grab this bit it's actually our
entire
lamp post so we want to rotate our lamp
post
from the exact middle you can see how
it's way off
when i'm rotating this you see that i
want to be able to rotate it around
the the center of this pole zero zero so
what we can do is i wonder if this works
if i hit the axis gizmo and reset psr
no that moves everything so then
what i would do you can actually just
type the numbers in
zero zero zero with the axis tool
selected
and what on earth for some reason zero
is
off center for us
huh that's not right okay so
for the lamp post maybe if we go to
the um the access center tool maybe we
can
use this and say we want to go
all the way towards
x all right so we'll go all the way
towards x hundred percent
and we'll go to the very bottom so minus
y
that takes us to about that point
but i feel like that's still not zero
zero
because if we rotate this you can see
how it
disappears it goes into the structure
it's just weird i feel like i don't know
how to reset this
um x should go to zero yeah that's not
zero unfortunately i'm gonna have to do
this by eye because i don't have the
answer i bet you chris knows
all right i'm gonna hit l yep gizmo tool
selected
and we're just gonna get this right to
the center point
the dumb way we're doing it the dumb way
all right boom that's at the center
and now when we rotate you can see how
it just
it works all the way around
so the whole point of this let's go back
to camera and just orient this a little
bit
over also one thing to note
this light is just off center
but in our image the light is
pretty far out to the left so i think we
can actually scale our lamp post
down a bit
and this is a case actually where our
gizmo we want our gizmo to be
um not where it is actually so maybe we
can go into lamp post
select both of those group those and
change this
axis
let's hop out of camera
we're gonna scale it down a little bit
and
move it out a little bit
we'll see if that works for us and we'll
go back to the lamp post
and just rotate it
that feels about right something like
like that i can get rid of these guys
sweet i think this is gonna be pretty
fun
get some nice volumetric light going
here and we can always reframe this
that's the thing is like i'm just kind
of framing it up so i can see
what's going on and after the fact you
know find the best angle you don't have
to match the photo exactly
but reuben hey thanks for the super chat
buddy appreciate you man
um yeah all you guys dropping these
super chats it helps out a lot it really
does
um doing these streams takes a lot of
time i got a lot of prep work and
um you know i'm obviously working on
this during the week too so
it all really helps i appreciate you
guys
um okay so you guys were telling me i
was in object space
i need to be in world space when i zero
out
my gizmo good good tip that was a basic
one i should know that
all right um renee
i think that's how you say her name um
what made me want to specialize in
cinema 4d
i'm starting in blender but when i'm
seeing pros like you makes
makes me question there's going to be
pros in every program i promise you
um and i'm certainly not a pro i'd say
i'm intermediate
but i appreciate that um there are going
to be pros in every single program
there's always going to be someone
better you
better than you and this would be
someone not as skilled as you no matter
where you're at in life
so don't let that discourage you um
i i know that ian hubert is a master
when it comes to blender
so you just need to check out his stuff
ian hubert um
i think mr was it robot soup i think is
his channel just look up ian hubert
you'll see
um he's absolutely absolutely incredible
and um yeah if blender's free so
you know why not dive in but i love
cinema because i've been using it for a
long time
it was my first 3d like real 3d program
and yeah like i'm just very familiar
with it i like a lot of the tools that
it has
all the mograph tools are just like the
best its dynamics are really easy
makes it very simple um
i freaking love it yeah and they hooked
me up too
freaking um paul at max on what a what a
guy
yeah he helps me out helps support the
passion so i appreciate them very much
maxon is a really cool
company it feels like a family it's nice
okay let's get these little modules in
place
god dang reuben thanks dude um thanks
for stopping by i'll see you next time
man
this this stream will be up on youtube
uh when i when i when i cut it off in
like the next hour and a half or so
um so come back and check it out but
thanks brother catch you later
all right um let's uh let's grab this
connector
and we see that there's lines up here
something like this
right and we will work these these
little bits in
let's go back to world space set that
gizmo right
we'll zero that out boom
now i can move it around this pole and
it'll just
perfectly stick
all right so the wires let's see the
wires
what's the best way to do the wires
i'm thinking these thin ones like one
two three
four five six all of this stuff
we're just gonna i think we're just
gonna use splines and duplicate these
splines
so let me hop into top view real quick
then
i'll get rid of my plane just for a
second
so i can actually get a better view of
what's going on
i can hide our figure so i can see
what's going on
okay that module's there okay that this
is all fine
now let's let's see
all right
so let's go ahead and grab the spline
pen tool
and we actually let's see
we can go linear on these on these
splines
and i'm thinking we're gonna start
everything from
zero zero all right we can always adjust
that
later and then i'm just gonna take this
out in a direction
maybe this direction who knows and we'll
hit escape
and we'll just make sure that this hits
zero
cool now back in our main view
that's i'm gonna be on the ground all
right so let's just make sure we select
the whole thing
in object mode and i'm gonna hit
s to snap to it and we'll pick it up
i'll pick it up sweet
alright so now we can actually control
boom
um this this spline here um
and i'm probably going to control it in
top view
and just see what it does in perspective
view okay
so it looks like they're trailing off
in i don't know this direction here
something like this
right and we want to thicken up these
wires these wires aren't
just um splines they need to be geometry
because when we
render this thing let's let's give it a
quick
render
all right let's um
[Music]
let's give it some sort of evening hdri
image
let's try this sunset campus
and it should
oh i see what's going on okay i'm just
gonna grab um i have
two octane skies going on one of them is
just the background image
set to visible environment so i'm gonna
change this color to
you know something like that and let's
let's actually hide it for a second
so we can see our first hdri and it's
dark this is an old hdri
oh it's power set to 0.1
there we go
and then we'll bring our background back
in
yeah something like something like that
we can
move the hdri around
but i think it was at the right angle
actually kind of backlit
yeah i'm just gonna bring
[Music]
no this is fine this is this is a
perfect example of what we're going for
okay
so you can see how we have the spline
but we don't see it in our in our render
it's very easy to fix so you basically
want to thicken it up
and you can do so by dropping in
a circle spline okay let me hop out of
camera
and i'll actually check camera so back
in
in octane i'll make sure check camera is
unchecked
then we'll hop out and now
our view our uh the live view is still
live or something's happening to it
i don't know what happened um but let's
just move this thing up here
all right so we're going to move the
circle spline generally
up in the area of the spline we'll
rotate it
i'm going to pause the live viewer let's
go 90
degrees holding shift okay and i'm going
to scale this thing down
and this will determine the thickness
of our spline okay so with both
the spline and the circle selected i'm
going to do what ctrl alt
okay and then we'll throw it into a
sweep and now when we
adjust the thickness of this spline you
can actually see it show up
as geometry here in the render
let's reload it yeah there it is
so we'll head back into camera view
we'll check the camera
yeah and there you go we got that
geometry
showing up let me throw a
like a darker texture on everything
just so we can see our silhouette
all right so i know we have a ton of
wires so i'm going to make a folder
called wires
and we'll do one called uh thin
thin wires and then we'll have a thicker
wires
folder but we'll do that later
and then we can do like these modules
and circuit boxes
and wire boxes and connectors
and fasteners we will just put this
in its own geometry and we'll call this
like uh
detail then we have the lamp post
telephone pole and ladder rungs ladder
rungs can go in detail
i usually try and keep my stuff as
organized as possible
when doing all this
um so how's everybody doing you guys
following along enjoying yourselves
give me a little thumbs up in the chat
if you guys are hanging in all right
feel free to ask any questions just at
me here at punisher
um i see a question have i ever used
houdini i have not
i have not used houdini i'm spending my
points in
unreal engine right now that's what i'm
learning
tila yeah here's the thing topo wire
all right i definitely feel i feel it
for sure
but here's the thing topple wire you
don't have control
over stuff like like this where it turns
and bends and everything
right and goes into very specific points
um
i i wonder though i wonder like
hmm
because with with topo wire i'm sorry i
was referencing something you guys
couldn't even see
these bends in turns and stuff or even
more intricately like these wires that
are wrapping around
the thicker wires or the combination of
wires
so you have doubled up wires and stuff
i'm just wondering if i can have the
control with topo wire
um so this is this is a tough one you
know we can we can go down
two different paths at this point you're
like what's the best way to do this i
feel like
maybe top of wire for some of this stuff
but like these loops
yeah maybe
hmm
alex thank you buddy thank you for the
super chat much appreciated
thanks for helping out um i'm excited to
see the results too enjoy that coffee
yeah all right so it looks like we don't
have enough control with top of wire
it's what at least what the chat
is agreeing with because it's really
cool topple wire is awesome
like you know you can do some cool stuff
let me just show you guys
so basically if i throw these two
spheres
um if i make a topo wire
and then i throw these two spheres
underneath it's going to make like
this geometry
right and then you can actually take
this and
let's see you can sag it which is super
cool
it'll sag down so i feel like this is
good for like background stuff
or just for you know whatever the heck
this is this is awesome you can take the
direction and kind of pinch them
together
and maybe get rid of some wires
if you don't want the danglies you can
distance limit the distance
at some point they should go away
but not for me
and then it's actually you can make it
uh dynamic too
which is really cool
um jamie that's a good question
oh matthew that's a good question too oh
man
lots of good questions all right so i
got i got three legit questions here
um we'll start from the top how do you
select an inspiration to work upon for
example
this photo here this photo
i took while i was on a walk i knew i
saw this and i was like this is cool i
was listening to some music
actually the song is playing in my bone
phones is the same song
i was listening to when i took this
picture that's weird
anyway um you know i was just inspired
by
the the the landscape around me i
have been trying to learn unreal engine
for the last month and a half i've been
working at that
so like these things are on the top of
my mind i'm focusing on those things
so those things are kind of up at the
top of my brain
i see something i'm like oh i want to
recreate this i want to make this look
real
i want to set this to a song i want to
make like a moody scene
so um that's definitely how i'm going
around
like taking pictures and coming up with
that stuff
next question what games am i excited
for that are coming out this year i'm
hyped for halo infinite
um okay so i am playing the last of us
two right now and it is so good
oh my god i i am in love with that game
right now
i cannot wait to see what happens i'm
like
seven eight hours in maybe nine hours in
yeah it's so good and then ghost of
tsushima i am very excited for
but i'll play that after i beat last of
us too
um and then jamie last question hey man
thanks for the stream
what do you do um
when a uh okay what do you do when a
project burns you out
example the storyboard changes when
you're already deep into the project
thanks for the wholesome c4d tips all
right so
yeah definitely take breaks take as many
breaks as you can
get outside try and work out that helps
me out a lot
get active get your sweat on that helps
me out a whole bunch
um just in general as far as life goes
but when a project burns me out and i'm
just not enjoying it like it's tough
yeah there's some jobs and some
sometimes where it's just like i'm not
enjoying this process
but i promise you're gonna feel really
good when you get it done it's gonna be
like a huge weight off your shoulders if
it's one of those projects
um i know i've had a number of those in
my life for sure
um i think we all have but um
fine try and find the thing that you
enjoy and find the value in what you're
doing
if you can say to yourself oh like
i may not enjoy what i'm doing right now
but i'm learning and like i'm getting
better for the future
then just hang on to that you know what
i mean and if and if a storyboard gets
changed in the middle of something like
i don't know maybe maybe that's like
something you negotiate you renegotiate
like look i did all this work this is
what we negotiated on
now you changed everything and i have to
do all this extra work
so that's extra fee you know so you can
like
the more you freelance or do your job
the more you can like kind of work those
things in your contract and stuff or
just
i think the more communication the
better with that kind of stuff
um and these bone phones these are trex
air aeroplex
i'll type it in here
and they're the best i i don't have to
say anything else
they really are the best okay
going back in let's um let's
let's add a background
all right this is the image we don't
need that i'm just gonna add a white
background
so we can see where our wires are going
okay
and i'll just take this down
to like point four so we can see what's
going on
all right and let's start duplicating
these wires
because after this is just texturing and
lighting and we'll be good
okay so
let's see and all right let's
uh
let's zero out our gizmo
okay and i'm just gonna start
copy pasting this thing and start
dragging it around so we have one about
the base
of of this guy coming down we have one
a little lower
um there's basically
three in between
the light post and this module
here so there's one above
there and then probably around
there cool
awesome so we can adjust the angle of
these guys
so let's grab these splines one two
three
go to top view we'll grab the end points
okay for all three of those hopefully it
should be all three
there we go okay
and it looks like let's see i just want
to get these
in place here
and we'll angle them down because
there's no way these lines are going
straight
this is probably something like that and
they are going to the
corner of the image actually
something like this right and we can
adjust each one a little bit
something like that
and like that now you you always want to
use real world reference
when you know recreating these photos
because real life has a ton of details
that you're not gonna know off the top
of your head so
um even just like the randomness and the
wire and like all these little details
and stuff
that that just goes such a long way
all right
i'm reading the chat here i'm gonna
going back and forth
i appreciate you guys staying in here
okay
let's keep adding these these wires
one two three all right so we got these
three what about this one up here let's
duplicate holding control and move this
guy up
about there okay and then we can hop
back into
our top view and grab
this spline here and just come up with
it
just a little bit
yeah something like that re-render the
scene
cool
and we have some up here and we actually
might use
top of wire for these guys just to give
them a little bit of sag
um we could do it with a bezier curve
but i think
top of wire is going going to actually
help us out in this situation
so let's hop out of the camera for a
second
so let's see boom
and let's make a cube
or even a null now we can do a cube all
right
let's bring the cube up this will be one
of our points
up here and we're going to control drag
our cube
out this direction and maybe down a
little bit
i'll make that top of wire
modifier there drop the cubes in okay
and the wire
the point count will just set to one i
guess by two goes to default by two
and we will drop our curvature
down like this and let's hop
into our camera and see what that looks
like
okay
so taking that second cube
let's bring it down
somewhere right in there now if we
adjust the curvature we can really get
more sag
with that
it's not just a straight line okay
and then let's make sure it's
renderable looks like it is
that looks great i'm gonna throw the
same
material on there cool
it looks like there
is another set just above okay so
let's duplicate and move those up
and now we adjust the top of wire uh
let's see the distance limit
so i feel like i'm getting something off
here with the distance limit um
[Music]
maybe i need okay maybe i need more
wires there we go
there it is sweet
and then we'll do a third one up top so
ctrl dragging
those cubes
and we'll make sure we put more wires
yikes
um what editorial am i using abdul are
you
are you asking me or somebody else
editorial what do you mean like this
reference thing here this is pure ref
i'm changing the seed to make sure i get
the right look
awesome
feels about right to me not perfect but
that's the idea
all right so those are all the thin
wires on that side let's just get these
guys
on the right okay so for that
i might just use topo wire
as well um
let me let me try doing something cool
here let's see
let's uh zoom in we'll make
a
oh what's the best way to do this
let's make a plane rotate at 90.
scale it in
and let's just
scale it up the length of this
telephone pole basically
and we'll go ahead and zero out the
width and height segments okay i'm going
to make it editable so now we just have
this like
really thin strip
and we'll go
and let's just see let's see if this
works let me copy this
paste it over here make a top of wire
and drop both of them in
and let's see
if i go to vertex right looks like it's
going to connect
these points here so if if we chop it
if we chop the plane
like there for instance will it draw
a line okay we'll not draw a line from
there
unless it needs to be dropped in again
nah that doesn't look like the case
alright so that test did not work
but that's okay
let's go back to the spline method
and we'll wrap this guy around this side
and we'll see if we can get maybe
some sort of sag in this by changing
this to
uh
maybe adding a point in the middle or or
just maybe maybe make it
bezier and adjusting
this bit here
very subtle
and it looks like it's bending there so
we need to up
the what is it uniform yeah we set it to
uniform
okay back into camera
and let's rotate this out
okay so this point here at the bottom if
we bring this down
it looks like it's coming out from this
angle and hitting that corner yeah
that's about right
and we'll just copy and paste
this up here so this will go
maybe up to this point
looks about right
and it actually looks like this one
starts like up here
but maybe we'll do a second one
or no that actually works
something like that
and then we have some wires off to this
side
so we'll take this sweep and we'll just
start duplicating stuff so
i'll go to like a side view
cool so this view down here and we'll
start duplicating this
and we'll change the thickness of one of
these we'll go like
0.35
just keep pushing it keep scaling
and then back down to 0.19
i don't know i'm kind of obsessed with
uh with light poles and
telephone wires i just love all the
detail that goes into them
sweet
that is awesome
digging this so far
now we have a couple lines that come out
to the side here
so we can probably get that
by duplicating these two
holding control and just going 180
on them
and taking those end points
one and two go back to top view
grab both of those end points there
let's see one two
in point mode and we'll just
pull them up
so it looks like they're cutting across
and these are
actually sitting in front we'll we'll
move all the wires in front because
there's no such thing as a wire going
straight into the middle of this thing
they're all just kind of like
on the outside of this pole so we'll
move that once we have everything in
place because it's really easy for us to
you know rotate these lines and wires
um from the center point
right
all right let's check in with you guys
how's everybody doing
could you add a displacement deformer
under the spline to give the jiggle
effect
ah that'd be an interesting test yeah
because if you look here you can see
this like
warbly effect here
um maybe you might also be able to do
that
huh i don't think a displacement
let's give it a test actually real quick
i would like to test that so we want to
see if we can get that warble effect
and let's just do a spline
we can do an arc whatever that's fine
we'll drop a
circle spline in and we'll just grab
both of those
hold ctrl alt throw it in a sweep
scale the arc down okay so the idea is
can we put a deformer in here to get
some jiggly some jiggly jigs in here
let's see if we hold shift
and drop a displacer in okay that
doesn't do it but maybe
if we
group those together
like this give it some
noise hey
okay that's promising so that means
if we take the global scale to like a
thousand
all right it's doing a weird thing where
it's like
making it thicker and skinnier in
certain parts
so i wonder hmm
interesting interesting okay maybe let's
take the global scale back down to
200 and we take
the height to
0.1 maybe 0.2
we can kind of get
some sort of detail in here maybe 0.5
is as far as we'd want to go but that
gives us a little bit
of like deformation
in the actual pipe
that's not bad i wonder if we use a
different type of displacer if that
would
or if we crank the contrast you just
don't want to go too intense with it
and i wonder actually if there's a way
to keep it uniform so
we can do um the noise
could be
a certain type of noise maybe
oh that's interesting
yeah a lot of experimentation and
testing we could do
but i'm wondering if there's like a
certain type of noise
that's uniform that will allow us
to like get
more wavy turbulence maybe
it's not bad
yeah that i mean it's it gives you a
little bit of something
definitely so that's an interesting
little detail that we might be able to
mess with
all right so
let's talk about any other wires and
then we'll place these modules and we'll
do
this little wire path here
this main one boom boom we'll do that
last
but let's get like let's get this bit
where it comes here and like loops
around a couple times i wonder if we can
do that with
topo wire so let me let me try this let
me go
and spawn a sphere right in here
too many spheres
let's move this up
hop out of camera view it's gonna be a
lot easier to see
so this will basically house our
our wires here
like right in here
something like that
and then we have a wire going up to
this point up here so holding ctrl
and just moving this to this point
okay so let's see if this works i'm
going to scale
this sphere way down let's maybe
actually make this sphere a
a null i wonder if this will work with a
null
let's take both of those and put it in a
topo wire
looks like it doesn't work with a null
so let's make it a cube
scale the cube way down
so you can kind of see the idea here we
want one line
going to a couple circles
so let's go back to top of wire let's
just set it to like two
maybe ten and we'll give it some sag
let's see uh under transform
just a little something like that let's
pinch the points together
no we don't need that okay i think we
just need
we need to work the distance
cut off something like that
and then we'll take
let's see we'll take the point count
down to like five
you
whoa set to vertex that's intense
so i'm just experimenting and messing
around
with these wires to see if there's like
a an interesting look
that works for us
let's render and see what it looks like
and we can uh we can lock
our viewport and set this to like 0.5
and so you can actually like see the
whole image that you're
that you're putting out
so this kind of works
maybe not my favorite
but you can see how top aware can help
us in certain situations
there is a draw function in c4d
yeah um so you could maybe come into
like
a side view like this and
sketch out like
one and
two right so those will be your splines
and you would just have to line them up
so let's see um
hopping out of camera view
take those splines
something like that and then just give
it a uh
that same sweep so we'll make a circle
drop those into the sweep bring the
circle way down
something like that you know you could
do
yeah i think you guys get the idea
okay
sweet what's up nicholas welcome
welcome to the chat
okay so we have most of our wires in
place we just need to add some detail
and stuff um
specifically like
this this bit of wiring here we need to
control
so i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to come into top view
and i'm going to hide all of our wires
just so we get a clear view of what's
going on let me
let me get rid of grid view for a second
so we'll go to filter work plane
in this background we can get rid of two
all right so we want to create this like
cross hatch
section of wire um what's the best way
to do this
so definitely it's it's like multiple
wires coming from one side
i think we definitely have like one
foundational wire that's just
going there it's like a little
crisscross pattern
um
this is this is tough this is just like
a lot of detail work here
so we know we want let's go into wires
grab our thin wires
control drag one of these out
let's just get the foundation right
first okay
so we'll go to our spline grab this line
here
so we can see what's going on and let's
just try and line this up by eye for a
second
so this point is coming at from the
bottom
and this point
is probably going off frame
around here okay
something like that and i can't tell if
the other spline is
it's probably above it's got to be above
yeah that makes the most sense
welcome visual we are doing splines by
hand
and man it's tough
oh okay
maybe we should use toppo wire for this
like
so if we have the main ones
right like this
and we set the radius to like point
three on these guys
i don't know i'm going to let the
thickness be built up from additional
splines
okay and then let's grab
another one of these
okay and it looks like the additional
splines are being added to the geometry
of
wires we already have in place okay
so let's bring our back background back
in
and let's get this guy in place let's
work in all of our detail
as much as we can here um so i'm gonna
hop out of camera
to get this guy in place
awesome all right so that's close
i just want to get this center point
like right
right in here boom
cool so now we can just rotate this
thing
god what oh no i was rotating geometry
that's not good
um wait i was rotating something
in geometry i see
i want this piece right here
detail cylinder module
and i want the gizmo to be
centered
to its midpoints i'll use the axis
center tool let's reset this
point center and execute so now it's
right in the middle
but why it's not switching
man that's tough okay so i'm gonna have
to
do this by hand nope not working
[Music]
oh that's working there it is
all right that's in place now
so we should be able nah that's tough
okay
scorn dude appreciate you thanks for the
super chat
if i add the displaced deformer as a
child the path spline it should
work better assuming you have enough
subdivisions
add the displaced deformer as a child
the passplan it should work better okay
so you're saying
it can actually deform the spline itself
if there's enough subdivisions in the
spline so let's give it a test
this is the test we had
let's put oh hey gilbert
come here hey bud
gilbert cat running around
so you're saying
to put this placer in here let's see
oh is it is it moving the spline it
should be moving the spline we'd like
for it to move the spline
we'll just take the contrast up like
crazy
oh yeah it's actually moving the spline
that's cool but it's not moving it left
and right
so maybe we change
this to there should be like an option
so that's 2d but we want to go in left
and right as well
you know how to get it to go the other
direction i'm not sure but this is
actually pretty promising
this is nice um
so then we could
change the contrast back to zero
choose a different kind of displacement
and smooth it out so we'll take our arc
and give it
uh
there we go
that's really cool
that's fun oh that's that's awesome and
you can probably animate all this stuff
too
it looks like music or electricity ooh
you could do uh electricity if you give
it like um
like an emissive material oh that could
be sweet
that's fun thanks corn
super cool
nice maybe we can mess with that later
when we add some detail in here but
let's let's get this
main bit down this is like the toughest
bit of detail
all right
so this guy needs to move
let's see
uh but here's the thing so
this little module
it's not 2d we actually want to see
one side of it like this so we need to
move
that means we need to move this cylinder
around and hopefully if i include this
bit the cylinder module in
the spline we can just rotate it
all together
so these two sweep one and two
there's just so much stuff going on
we'll zero out
all that
and there we go so now we're actually
seeing
into that cylinder
cool that feels that feels correct
something like that awesome
this is a lot of work guys
i hear you guys on the spline thing i
got to focus on just getting these wires
placed first that's the most important
thing
otherwise we're here till next christmas
these things always go so long i'm gonna
try and get out here in
three hours that gives me one more hour
to texture and light and render this
thing but
we'll do what we can um also for you for
those of you who don't know
next week i'm gonna be taking this scene
and trying to get
um similar results in unreal engine
okay because i'm i'm good with with
octane and cinema i just
need i need to apply the same things and
get the same quality out of unreal
so this will be a nice experiment that's
next week okay
and i'm going to get some volumetric fog
some real time volumetric fog going and
try and get some particles and flies and
or not flies they would be like moths or
something
underneath this light and it'd be nice
to get my phone
hooked up to unreal engine to be able to
film you know this
this scene all all in real time so i
think that'd be sweet that's next week
all right let's
get this last little bit here
i want to rotate this down just a hair
awesome okay so now let's make this
intersection
this uh
little guy is helping out and there's
wires coming out of this
curving around this bit right here boom
going this way
so it's this intersection that we need
to draw a wire around
um
and there's like i feel like there's a
there's a whole bunch of wires and
intersection
intersectory bits in this but this
square right here is where all of this
stuff is
really happening okay
so let's hop out of the camera
and see
[Music]
what's going on all right so this is
this is confusing
this is very confusing oh boy
yeah i don't know oh
i don't know where these wires are in 3d
space
that's the issue it looks like
this wire is definitely going off to the
left
and connected to this bit so
that's going left and then but but this
is taking a hard
turn off in this direction i just need
to make sense of this
and it's going
down off in that direction
so really what's happening is it's
coming off of this bit here
and making a turn that way
and then let's see
okay so it looks like there's an
intersection
and this is not connected to the light
pole
it looks like it's actually connected
god this is confusing it looks like this
is actually connected to
this bit here and it's just coming off
of that
and that's what's causing our
intersection there
so this would need to be bigger than
this can come up a little bit more
or no i wouldn't be up it would be
maybe it would be up
so it's doing it looks like it's doing
something like that
dude wires are confusing
these get pushed out oh no they need to
continue on their
on their path otherwise this bit gets
off
so
something like that and then these guys
got to go
this way
all right it's getting closer
alex why is my second oh no jacob
why is the the second after effects icon
white that's because it's after effects
beta that's where you're getting
that rotobrush 2 for you guys for those
of you guys using after effects
you can get to it through creative cloud
[Music]
and
let's see on the i just wanna make sure
this thing doesn't have my email
all that stuff okay yeah should be good
so on the left
you should see beta apps and then you
can download after effects beta
and that's what has rotobrush 2 hooked
up and everything so
definitely be checking that stuff out i
know that um windbush
put out a tutorial on how to use it so
check out wimbush's channel for that
okay let's let's start doing this
um let's just go in here and
see how this is gonna work um let's take
let's take this guy
ctrl drag him down just a little bit
and we're gonna thicken this wire up
times like five
so it's this bottom one
sweet all right this will be under thick
wires
and we'll give this like a point six
yeah so much thicker all right um
and we're just going to start moving
these points around
and we want it to curve into
this cylinder here
so whenever i can just control drag this
awesome
and we'll just get it right right in
there
i'm hoping i can change
the style of this
and actually like maybe
shift-click both of these and go soft
yeah and it'll just go right in
awesome
and we just you know we just build it up
so
using this as a reference you know we're
just gonna
keep working on this um so it looks like
we have a thicker wire coming out the
back end of this
so i can continue this wire
through
man this feels like a cornelius dominic
render this is
this is deep
cool we got that one point selected i'm
going to ctrl drag it out
and through to this side here
and this will actually just go all the
way down
all right so we have it looks like this
module this box right here
is fixed to
this rung
here
and we want to lead some wires from this
out
to that main little little hub there
just like this
all right so we'll spawn let's do a
little wire
um let's grab a thin wire
i'll bring this down and i wonder if we
can use the
transfer tool
we can awesome so we can use the
transfer tool on spline points
that's very helpful
we'll grab this guy
and see if we can't we want to wire it
from this point down to the intersection
it looks like this is
man this is so deep this is so deep
like the the amount of detail on this is
honestly
scary and painful
there's got to be an easier way
it's just too much
all right so we got that there let's see
if we can connect this
down into actually down and around so
we'll go here
i'm going to control drag out
a little bit
and just connect it here to this bit
and send it down the line
and then hopefully we should be able to
take that spline and set it to like
cubic nope
b spline kind of works um maybe linear
and then just selecting
these two corner ones and setting them
to
soft is yeah looks like the best way to
go
let's go back in the camera and see what
we got
oh my goodness
oh that is
that is tough guys we have so much to do
to get
this and i don't think we can do it here
on the stream
this is just hours and hours of work you
guys see how much time is put into this
stuff oh
maybe it'd be worthwhile to put together
some like
sort of construction wire plug-in
for cinema 4d something where like
you can easily draw something out
there's got to be a workflow for this
it'd be nice to figure that out but i
don't think i'm gonna figure it out here
today on the stream
but you guys get the idea you can see
how intense this
this whole wire setup can be i i think
i'm going to
maybe just drop one more wire
in across the top and then
move on to texturing and lighting
because i need to get out of here by one
at least
so i can get on that custom hdri
tutorial for you guys
goes live on tuesday
all right visual he says i think what
might have helped would have been
building the light and wires
at right angles like they would be in
real life
and then messing with your camera to get
the perspective yeah i think so man
yeah getting the right angles and and
then
tweaking it from there because like
there are some angles that are off
but for the most part yeah i think the
right angle
method is probably the way to go on this
yeah and just build it all out from like
a top
view you know build out a couple
different structures from top view
all right i'm going to do one last one
last wire i'm just going to like
take this guy will duplicate
and i'm going to just change the
thickness
and we'll do the same for this one here
and we can always come back in and add
all that good detail that really makes
this feel real
you know um lastly i'm going to just get
in here and make sure that this stuff is
included because i'm all the
modeled it out you know um
so might as well add that stuff
okay um evolver yo what's up chris thank
you sir
i appreciate you very much very very
much
you've been very kind to me you've
helped me out with unreal engine
helping me get that photo real look i'm
trying to go for man so thank you so
much
next week i'm dropping this scene into
unreal to try and bring it to the next
level but we're gonna we're gonna light
it and texture it here in octane right
now
at least after i get these little bits
in place so real quick let me just go
to my geometry detail
and it should be in here somewhere
fastener
yeah it's this fastener
all right
so i'm gonna hop out of the camera and
just place these things
around
so roughly we got one there we got
one here and we got one up here
cool um and then i want to take these
blinds and make sure that the wires are
actually in front
of
this pole so i'm going to grab these
points
right in the middle
and bring them out
and yeah these these are definitely on
right angles
oh john malcolm okay perspective crop in
photoshop to flatten out the wire layout
to make a plan view might actually have
helped that's a cool idea
down for that and then you can actually
import the splines from photoshop man
that's the way to do it
ah that's the way to do it
i was using it for the corridor um
domino video too
man definitely the way to go i might
i might redo this when i have some free
time this week is going to be insane
i'm trying to crank hard so i can go on
vacation next week
oh um
all right let's just keep tweaking these
last
little bits
cool all right um let's get these
backside
ones here might be able to select all
three at once
all right last bit i'm going to place
this guy
cool that'll do it
okay let's uh let's lighten texture this
thing so
as far as lighting goes personally i
enjoy
this lighting setup
right here um
i like to see i mean it's kind of it's
kind of like the opposite you know it's
you have the light background with the
dark wires this one you have
the dark background with the light wires
so it all kind of depends on the vibe we
want to go for but
i want to try and get this look right
now
all right so
let's start texturing this thing i'm
first i'm going to start with uh just by
going to bridge and grabbing this like
wood beam
texture and they might have i mean i was
looking
for something like a light post or a
light pole but they don't really have
one they have square ones
but we'll find something
all right
oh nice we got some classic horse manure
a green bell pepper
this trash can
doesn't look that good honestly huh i'm
surprised
whoa yes ice cliffs
yes ginger yes i love ginger
dude mega skins is the best yo
they got snowy stuff
all right i love it when they put out
new stuff
cool they got daggers
all right now we're back to the normal
stuff okay so let's try 3d assets
i i may have actually saved some of
these um
[Music]
favorites maybe nope okay
3d assets would
i think it was like all the way at the
bottom
you have like these these old boards and
then you have
these guys right here the worn wooden
beams
and you might be able to use this
and kind of stack them up
so they're about a little taller than a
person so you could probably get away
with three or four
stacking three or four to get this look
um otherwise
like we could just look for a let me
actually
let me heart these favorite these in
case we want to come back
um
[Music]
we could do a just a surface
so instead of 3d assets we just go to
surfaces and we go to
wood
i guess it would be um other
we need something really worn down
[Music]
and none of these really feel like
they're doing it for me
maybe bored
but i still feel like no this isn't
gonna work for us log all right here we
go
but it's like one log it's not just a
bunch of logs this
might work old log wall might
work for us
this one this one here yeah this might
work for us
we just don't want to make sure it's
tiled too closely we want something a
little larger so
we can search for all sizes we can
search for like
a meter to two maybe two to four meters
and it looks like we only have a meter
to two to work with
which we might be better off just using
the 3d scan
hmm
let's try the 3d scan so let's go back
to
the favorites here let's grab these guys
download settings we want material
preset
for it's offline specular
lot zero level of detail
yeah we want all that good stuff let's
download it
we'll do the same here
and download it so we'll let that do its
thing
um anything else i think i think the
other stuff we can actually use
grayscale gorilla's everyday material
pack
and you know just get that metal going
so maybe we'll
i think i lost connection for a second i
should be back
if you guys hear me just give me a
little thumbs up i think i'm i'm good to
go
um but yeah if you guys are using octane
you have access to
the live db viewer here so we'll open
that up
sweet awesome thanks guys
so this is the live db viewer um
you can search anything you want with
octane and there's like a
whole bunch of textures made by the
community for you to download but i'm
going to be using
the everyday materials collection from
grayscale gorilla
and once this is done freezing here we
go car paint
let's just go to metal and grab some
warn something
hmm
we could try this
rusted metal o6 right here let's try
this guy so i'm going to right click
download it it'll pop right in
and then we'll try
this iron corroded look too we'll
download that
sweet so they're just right down here
and we drop just drop them on
let's actually hop out of camera view to
see what's going on
now we need to get the mapping correct
so i'm going to go into the material
and we want to adjust the way it's
projected so i'm going to grab a
projection node
and just pipe the projection node into
all these guys and we're just going to
set it to box
and that's gonna flatten it out make it
look real nice
so you can see how it just makes it a
bit more uniform right
and did we bevel this we didn't wait
i feel like we did not bevel this thing
we did apparently
i guess we did
let's grab these guys
and we can honestly just hit it with
like
a matte black
0.1 down the board roughness we can go
like 0.3
maybe 0.01 is closer to what we're going
for
yeah it just basically black out those
little bits
but i'm leaving a little bit of gloss so
we can catch some of the light there
um these metal steps
these look to be
let's see here
a little glossy definitely rusted and
crusty
so let me grab that iron and do the same
projection
tweak to these and we'll just
distribute these two textures across all
of our like
metal detail
okay
very nice
and we can oh that's that's really nice
i feel like that's more like it
yeah okay so let me
let me see here ladder rungs i'm just
going to apply that rusted material to
the entire ladder run cloner
and it looks like it needs to be scaled
way down so we'll take the tiling up to
like
10. maybe 100
is that doing anything
okay maybe it just needs to go back to
one
yep very nice
all right let's get like a rubber
material
for this like or a plastic for these two
these little housings so i'm going to go
back into
the live db viewer
and let's go to would it be organics
or where is it plastics maybe like a
black
plastic aged that's not bad
or this rubber maybe
i'm gonna try for the rubber
and we'll hop into here and we'll
definitely give the rubber
that uh that projection
adjustment that's the only thing with
all of these you just need to give it
the projection adjustment so
it works properly boom okay
and we'll apply this to
this guy
so that's shining nicely
and i swear i had some top pieces with
this like where did they go
oh they just didn't get scaled up or
anything um maybe
grab those and scale them up a little
bit
there we go
cool and then we'll do the same for this
guy over here
boom so that's shining nicely cool
and i think we can just apply this
material to
the wires too because it looks like a
nice little wire material i like it a
lot
so let's just take everything that makes
up these wires
okay
and i'm going to apply this rubber
material
to the wires
so it has a nice like glossy
material set up like that okay so far so
good
let's get this little module this box
here
which is just floating in the air i
guess
oh because i moved that one wire okay
yeah let's adjust this
the wire box cool
then we'll take this spline
and adjust that as well
yeah right about there
sweet
why is my rtx off you know i just got
this rtx card how do i
what do you mean off how do i turn it on
jacob help me
yeah what do you mean
the stream is lagging are you guys doing
all right
octane device settings
settings post settings
account other
i might just have to look this up later
unless you can tell me exactly where it
is
device gpu
render priority device settings
i have never been in this menu
use rtx acceleration
huh
nice
yeah i've never been in this menu
well let me know um
whoa wait what
well that's way faster
crazy okay thanks appreciate it
all right just texturing these guys up
awesome all right and then for the
actual
light pole
i'm going to copy the iron texture
and tweak it a little bit
because it's a bit too shiny
because we want to go for more of like a
plastic look
all right so let's open up this iron
i'm just gonna put this up into this
window here
cool alright so
i just want to adjust the roughness
so we'll take the roughness up to like
2.5 or something and
we'll take the rgb and i want to just
drop some of the contrast so i'll do
color correction
actually it's probably going to be more
of a gradient
and we'll take the black and make it a
dark gray instead
cool all right let's hop back into
camera view and see what we're looking
at
now the last thing is definitely
the wood um pole here so we want to make
sure we get that
right um let's go back to bridge and see
yep our materials
are downloaded now we just need to
export them right so we'll go to export
settings
we don't want unreal right now we want
cinema 4d
yep yep
and grab both of those and
export
you guys hanging in doing all right
we're almost done here we're going to
wrap up the texture get the lighting
nice
and then we'll export and or rather
we'll render and while we
render um i'll announce the winners
of this week's um i always forget then
of this week's weekly challenge i will
announce the winners of this week's
weekly challenge and issue out the next
challenge
and then we'll just maybe drop the
render into photoshop and see what we
can do
and call it a day
all right so those are importing in
right now
all right so we got our wood beam in
here
it doesn't actually look that nice
i wonder why usually octane or usually
uh
huh mega scans is looking real nice
hmm
maybe we will have to go with the
service because this does not look good
now it might be my lighting so let me
let me just give it a shot here um
[Music]
let's take our centerpiece
all right and then we'll actually zero
out let's hide the center piece
let's zero this back out
and we want to scale this up so
it matches the original size
okay
we have to hide that with a bunch of
stuff i i think i'm just gonna find a
service
that works better for us so
you know we looked we looked at mega
scans we didn't really find much
let's see if rd textures will help us so
let's go textures real displacement
textures
and like let's look at their overview
here and find their wood
um shoot i may not have their wood
materials
yeah it doesn't look like the case let's
try polygon
good old andrew price go to wood
um
[Music]
old wood
no not really
what's in other nope
planks maybe
nah i think bridge is probably our best
bet now
so let's go back
to wood and i believe it was
plank it was one of these
at least i'm pretty sure it was one of
these
it's gilbert
hey bud oh
we're trying to find our wood texture
all right gilbert
oh hey bud
all right let's try and find this wood
all right i think it was on our board
wooden paneling this might work um
let's download this
yeah that's a good one and then maybe
there's another
i guess that's the one huh that's the
one
let's give it a shot
oh
and export sweet
oh man 19 year old cat that's crazy
gilbert is not even one yet
my my other cat passed
at about 10.
and that was last year so that's awesome
we have a 19 year old cat that is crazy
huh noah
no he's 10.
okay let's get that
cylinder back in here boom all right
let me hide the floor
and let's see if we can't get something
nice going here
drop the wood texture on
and the mapping is is off so
let's go in i'm gonna change this to
octane glossy
let's go in here and we just need to put
that projection node on all this stuff
and set the projection to box that way
it kind of makes everything uniform
and when you have displacement hooked up
in octane it will not work
oh actually wait no i have to do this
the other way
oh wait no there is no displacement
never mind we're good
but maybe i think for this i need
displacement
yeah i think we need displacement for
this one
so in that case this box projection will
not work
we'll throw a displacement node down
and we'll link up our displacement
okay so now let's see let's set the mid
level to 0.5
and we'll set it to 8k resolution
height of 4 inches yeah that's fine for
now let's go to the material here
in our objects panel
and let's scale it down here okay
let's set the two let's try cubic
yep that already looks nicer
and i wonder if we can scale it so let's
try tiling it twice
or maybe 1.5 we don't want to see the
repetitions
all right we'll take the iron and i want
to
darken up
this texture a little bit it's a little
too bright for me and i might actually
brighten up the wood
man you really can't beat this
this worn um wooden post this wooden
beam i think
really the best way to do this is like
either go to rd textures and download
some of their stuff or photo scan
something yourself
because that's really nice
i'm certainly missing that here
and i think getting that right getting
that detail is really going to help
bring this whole thing together but
we'll see what we can do here
again lighting wise i want to go for
something more like this
all right so let's set our background
color
or even our octane sky let's just set
our octane sky
to a color instead and i'm just going to
sample
yep that dark gray there
and i'm really going to crank this light
so this is an emissive texture
but we want to get it something like
this
and we might even have to cheat it but
we'll see here
now this is perfect the light is right
above all the stuff
it should catch it real nice
so we'll go to the emissive material
and let's
crank this to like a thousand
already that's looking cool it's
catching those
those bits nicely and i'm also wondering
too we can probably cheat it where we do
let me actually add
an octane camera this is my favorite
part once we have everything ready to go
and lighting once we get to lighting oh
this is where it all comes together
let's check the camera imager tab i
always uh maybe maybe we can do a color
correction bit we need to do like
kodachrome okay that's yeah definitely
too intense
but that's because i think we have to go
to 2.2 yeah
sweet all right we'll do saturate to
white
um we'll set that to 0.2
because if i give the light kind of a
greenish tint let's see we can tint the
light actually
and but we want glow so i'm going to go
post processing and
glare blur will set the one
and let's do
bloom power of like five
so this is too blown out obviously and
we want something more along
the lines of this right here
so maybe 2.5 and
it would just be 2.5 divided by 2. so
like 1.75
but that star is really intense and
you'd want to get this
close um i know that uh
that unreal engine has a really nice
lens flare kind of effect
maybe we angle this
yeah something like that or we go
somewhere like that you know you can
mess with that stuff
but
maybe we give it like kind of an
anamorphic look
um but let's change the color of this
light
so let's go into our node editor
and grab an rgb spectrum
and we'll give it like uh
let's see
we'll set this to kind of like a
tungsten
cool yeah um
maybe dial it back a little bit we can
try green like a fluorescent
that's kind of cool i feel like our
bloom is a little intense
that's cool i want to be able to see the
detail in there you know
all right this is looking cool i like
this
so adding some fog will actually really
make this
nice but before we do that i just want
to see if i can't beef up this light a
little bit more
so i'm going to make an octane area
light
and let's see if we can't
yeah let's just make an octane area
light let's bring it up
like two meters i want to get it right
in place
you know there's a better way to do this
i'm gonna click that light right there
the lamp post
hold control then make oh it won't work
weird we'll use the transfer tool
that won't work weird all right um we'll
just manually
get this light in place then i guess
something like that
rotate it 90.
and then come up with it
and we'll give it a
a spherical
kind of map here let's do what is the
details rectangle
um disk that works
so it's just kind of beefing up the
light
and we can go to visibility and make it
just not camera visible right
and we'll we'll want to make sure that
the light color
matches with our emissive color so i'll
take this
rgb spectrum copy it
go to our light node view
paste it in and just make sure we pop
that into texture so it's the same color
now there is a way to do volumetric
lighting here um let me see i actually
think it's with a
with a spotlight an octane spotlight
but maybe what we can do
is give it a little fog volume so
let's save it and actually i'm going to
give it
just a bit of vignette
that's nice
cool and then for the fog volume
basically
we'll make a object
octane fog volume let's pause the
renderer for a second and hop out of
camera view
and when i make a octane fog volume it
will crash your system pretty quick so
take the voxel size editor up to like
100 and let's get this fog right under
the light
and fill our scene with it just grow
these bounds here
something like that then we can hide the
fog volume from view
hop back into camera view and we just
want something very subtle here
so right off the top it just turns black
because it's so thick
um so we'll go to medium hop in here set
the density to like
0.1
that's way too much um so scattering
and absorption let's
we might be able to leave those as is
but we'll take density to 0.01
0.000 maybe
and just something very very subtle up
here is going to go a long way
and the beauty of unreal engine is the
fact that it does
this kind of stuff so fast
um it knocks it out immediately
so that'll be next week we'll go over
how to do that in octane
but this isn't bad you know like we can
definitely do with a lot more wires
um
i'm wondering if instead of a volume we
could do
um an octane
spotlight
and we'll move the octane spotlight
right underneath you can see how it
by default comes in with like this
volumetric effect
you can actually control the spread
let's see if we have any control over
this volumetric effect here
um we definitely let's see visibility
i guess it needs to be visible
i haven't really used these too much so
i don't know what effect
to mess with um
and i don't know if it's under
light settings oh yeah uh no
the light medium
so it's a similar setup
ah but i'm not the biggest fan of that
it doesn't look doesn't really look good
let's bring our volume back in
and i think the rest we can do in
photoshop with some color correction
just messing with my light settings the
intensity of the light and everything
it's actually really cool
now i don't use denoiser too much
because i do like the um
i'll only use the denoiser if i'm in a
rush obviously i'm not really in a rush
um so i'm gonna let this render here um
and then we'll we'll make it look nice
in photoshop
so let me just set this up
we'll do like uh
i don't know two thousand by
twelve hundred
current frame
i'll leave the vignette for photoshop
so i'll get rid of it here
and samples will do
oops um wait where am i going here
there we go we'll do 1500 samples
adaptive sampling all right
all right so we'll let that go
and in the meantime
it's time to announce the weekly
challenge winners
all right
and yeah i'll definitely put the final
render on discord we'll let this go
we'll let this do its thing
so all right this week
um or i guess last week i issued the
challenge of doing
a macro render of an insect it was
actually one of your guys's
suggestions here on the stream i think
we'll do it this way every time where
we'll just kind of suggest
some things you guys will leave your
suggestions and we'll pick one from
there
um so let's uh let's go ahead and take a
look
at the five winners of this week's
weekly challenge
and the cool work that they put out
there's some really creepy stuff
some creepy crawlies all right
macro insects here we go all right
so first off this is somebody who
consistently wins these things because
the work they put out is just really
really nice
um and uh yeah we'll kick it off with
visual
very nice render of a ladybug very
simple
i like it a lot um i love your colors
the green and red the classic contrast
that nature
is very nice i wonder if you did like
the
uv paint tool in cinema 4d here to get
these
that looks really cool yeah and i love
your camera settings everything's
looking really nice and
like it does feel like this is a little
like
noisy but i i like that
and and i think you actually added some
noise to your render and i really do
enjoy that because
it makes it feel real it really does
and that's something that we're going to
be doing in photoshop when my render is
finished is adding some noise and stuff
and some grain but this almost looks
like like lens flare dust i love it
it's really nice very nice touch um
yeah i could totally see this as like a
it's like an iphone background or
something
so visual congratulations you are a
challenge winner this week
and hey it's melanie what's up thank you
for the super chat
you're the best i appreciate you she
says hello there i hope you're doing
well and are healthy i saw the adobe
care stream the other day and it looked
like
dobby made a cameo with you guys when
the stream froze
um yeah i think i kicked a wire or
something and it just like
knocked the stream out it was really
funny and i'm glad we saved it we got it
back
but yeah that was a good time um
[Music]
but yeah visual congrats you are
a challenge winner this week once again
okay next up we have someone
who you guys may recognize and that is
ice cream paint job
really gross yeah this is um nasty
there's a
ton of ants eating this m
m and if any of you guys have recognized
the m m
then go ahead and give a little thumbs
up in the chat
um but uh i love how
you added motion blur to this again
another
really good small detail to
take it away from that clean render look
but here's the thing it looks like you
added motion blur on top of your film
grain
your film grain should be on top of your
motion blur
the grain is never blurry it's just the
image
and then your grain comes on after the
fact so that's just a tiny little detail
to watch out for
but i do love the motion blur detail
these ants look disgusting
they're getting all up in here um
nice color yeah great composition
and it gives me some tingles really
gross so congrats ice cream paint job
you are a winner this week
once again keep up the good work man you
guys are doing amazing stuff
um next up we have
m m design m design
and they put together this hilarious
spider-man
spider this is so cool very unique
i just love this this is great yeah this
is this is an awesome render
i love your colors your render quality
is very nice your lighting is very nice
the background is you know blurred out
looking good it looks like you also have
some grain going on here some nice film
grain
um maybe this is a little too clipped
and saturated
here these lights i'm seeing these rings
of blue
um but that's okay hey you got it looks
like you got
water along the spider web
this is great it looks like you like
scattered some
scattered some spheres across like the
geometry and the vertex
points of of this web that's a really
nice touch very good
but yeah look at the materials on this
thing it's really good the way it
catches the light
and it actually has this like hexagon
hexagonal is that the word hexagonal
pattern across the top of it
yeah m design great work congratulations
you are a winner of the weekly challenge
this week keep it up keep it up
everybody you guys are doing a great job
awesome okay um so another
winner this week is
also a spider render there's a lot of
spider renders a lot of good spider
renders
um and it was tough to choose from
because there was
there's a lot of really good ones so
this guy here david katz
put this together and
this is incredible this is so good
the render quality is ridiculous you
have some dust and atmosphere in this
in the air amazing your spider webs are
really nice i don't know what you used
for that but
it looks great you have hair across the
spider it's disgusting
your materials are really nice
you know maybe see a little bit of
geometry here but i think that's okay
i can't tell did you add any grain
it's hard to say because there's a lot
of particles in the air and stuff
um
but yeah your camera settings are really
nice your depth of field is great you
got this screw
right in here it looks like i don't know
why that's so dark down here
so definitely watch out for that next
time um and then you have these little
baby spiders running around
this is so good congratulations
uh david katz you are a challenge winner
this week you should be proud
keep it up okay and our last winner
for this week put together something
absolutely incredible
i love it so much and it is this image
right here by
bdb 400.
i love the colors on this it almost
looks like a normal map
and no diffuse but it looks so cool it's
metallic
the detail is insane in this it's
really really nicely put together you
got the fur and the hair going here
on this fly and it's on this branch the
depth the depth of field is really
really nice here
um and the muted background colors
really bring out
this fly you can't miss it obviously
it's like the main focus of the thing
but it stands out so much because the
colors
of the fly are contrasted really well
with the background here
so congrats bdb 400
you are a challenge winner this week i
think this might be your first
win of all time so congrats
all of these renders will be up on the
discord server in the challenge
winner channel right
join the server link is in the
description if you aren't already it's
really fun
join these challenges right so
in the past there's been a number of
prizes
and i'm working to get more prizes for
you guys
because it's really fun and it gives
people incentive to create
even though you shouldn't be creating
for the prize you should be creating to
learn
and because it's fun because you enjoy
it you know you guys are here
you know so um
what do you guys want to do for a
challenge let's figure out the challenge
this week
i am open to suggestions hit me up
in the meantime let's take this render
and bring it into photoshop and tweak a
little bit of the colors
and while we do that i might actually
render out another one with a lot higher
um samples so let's try 3500
and we'll render that but not overwrite
render two
all right so let's bring this in
awesome so the first thing i'm going to
do is drop in
some film grain so i just had like an
overlay i just googled
film green texture
let's see where are you tmax 100
and i just set that to overlay
but you have to make sure it's
rasterized first
oh we must be in some sort of weird like
32-bit yeah we just
let's try 16-bit
or 8-bit
now let's go 16 because we want to
adjust the color have the most
control over our image
then we set it to overlay and then we
have some like nice film grain here
and i'll definitely want to blur it a
little bit so i'll go filter blur
a gaussian blur is totally fine but like
point
one
even 0.5
0.25 just something
to get away from like that very obvious
like cg feel you know
okay so taking a look back in the chat
here and we're talking about
weekly challenges so let's just start
reading off some of this food renders we
did ramen
at one point that was really fun
animation
armor stairs oh theme
stairs that's actually pretty cool
stairs could be sweet
um what about what about a story in a
genre
okay interesting i feel like every every
good render has a story to it
um so there's always a chance to add
story to your renders
dinosaurs like lego
lego that's a good one
oh man okay dragon time environment some
footprints
video game props still life guns
cave optical illusion oh man optical
illusion
we did the chrome ball one kind of an
optical illusion not really
a mini planet we did a planet
okay um i'm really digging lego
and stairs the stair theme
but i think lego is going to be a lot
more open so i'm just going to say
lego is the challenge for this week you
guys have one week
to render some legos um
build your render with legos only lego
bricks
only as if you put together
like your render it should it should fit
into the lego movie alright you can only
use lego pieces
render it however you want light it
however you want build
anything you want but just make sure
it's only made from legos
all right i really look forward to your
guys's renders this week for that
because
man i used to love playing with legos i
mean i still love playing with legos i
think they're the best
um yeah this is gonna be good this is
gonna be really good
and i'm wondering if we can work out a
prize
hmm
maybe
maybe whoever wins this
gets like a 20 credit
or maybe 25 credit to a lego of their
choice
and i'll send it to you if you
don't live like in australia because
shipping is expensive
we'll figure that one out but it'd be
cool to send like a little lego prize or
something
or a lego version of you maybe i don't
know
um let me do some research on that no
promises yet
but i think if you live close by ish
um so that shipping isn't ridiculous
you know i might send like first place i
can't send all five but maybe first
place
gets like a little lego or something so
what to figure that one out but
check out the discord server the link is
in the description i'm going to leave
the rules and everything uh for this
challenge
right in the uh the weekly challenge
channel
man this is a mouthful i'm just talking
a whole lot
my jaw hurts my butt hurts
i need to get lunch let's bring in this
render the the high quality one just
finished
not really much of a difference there
yeah there's a little bit you can see a
little bit there it's
definitely finer i'll do one more
and we'll actually add the denoiser so
let's enable that denoiser
and let's go yeah 3500 again
render 3 and then in octane render you
want to make sure under main that you
use denoise beauty pass so you check
that
give that a render and how long did that
take
uh picture viewer there you are
only five minutes all right so we'll
check back in five minutes
we'll tweak this image here
and we'll try and do it with adjustment
layers so we can just swap out our image
alright so
what should we do vibrance maybe we
crank the vibrance a little bit
and then we do maybe
hmm some curves mess with the curves
a little something like that just makes
it pop a little bit
all right and let's see if we can't do
like uh i see i wouldn't adjust this in
adobe camera raw but i want to update
the picture so
tom yo thanks for the super chat man
yeah the discord is fun make it
make it your own have fun inside there's
a lot of different things for everybody
so
um it's definitely a good time i
appreciate you man thank you thank you
oh man merch as the prize i need i need
some merchandise
here's the thing though if i had
merchandise what would you guys want to
buy would you guys buy
t-shirts would you guys buy stickers
would you
i don't even know i have no idea i know
that i'm releasing that
custom hdri pack on tuesday
along with the custom hdri tutorial but
that's not really merch
it's just kind of like a digital product
dude this image is looking nice
like this is this is good
let's adjust the hue and saturation
let's take the greens down just a little
bit
and some of the yellow
like this this is pretty sweet
i'd like to sci-fi this out just a
little bit
i think that'd be nice um i don't know
how exactly but i think it's probably
with more
geometry than with like photoshopping i
might be able to add some like lights
along these wires and stuff
but man look how good this turned out
this here
like this up here this is really nice
um let's add a vignette yeah definitely
gotta add the vignette
oh man t-shirts you guys buy t-shirts
oh carlos yeah dude let me know let me
know
um i hadn't updated the print shop in a
while but
what i want to do is actually throw in
some of my cg renders to the print shop
so if you guys wanted to
purchase some of my cg renders that you
like you can get those from the print
shop print them out make them look
really nice for you
um t-shirts are always great okay uh
stickers and masks
um gilbert and teddy
fan art kim likes that a lot
she's nodding and saying yes please
please she said please make sure you say
please
okay let's add our vignette and let's
add a little uh
lens flare here okay so
um vignette you know what i'm gonna go
crazy
just in general
i kind of want to take this into after
effects
this is my janky way of doing lens
flares
all right let's save it
png sure that's fine
let's open up after effects and i'm
going to use optical flares for this
lens flare
yay uh john cari thank you
for the super chat you guys are awesome
this is like the most super chats i've
ever got minus that one time i did all
those frog jumps and then blew out my
knee
the day a day later um but yeah i'm glad
that just the educational part of things
inspires you guys to help out a little
bit so i appreciate that
i'm glad you've been learning a whole
bunch of these live streams man that's
the whole point
yeah hey gilbert
hey bud we're almost done we're gonna
add a lens flare it's gonna look real
nice
what do you think about that
okay um all right so you guys say
wallpapers i don't know how i feel about
that
selling digital wallpapers you know
that's how do you
like how do you first off
how do you prevent people from just like
you know uploading that and then it's
over and then it's like okay well what's
the point
and then also like shouldn't those just
be free anyway like i don't know
but then with the print shop you don't
want to have a wallpaper so large that
like people just
can make their own prints you know so i
i'm conflicted on that
i don't know if you guys would buy a
wallpaper
what would you what would you spend on a
wallpaper like a buck
250 or something it'd have to come with
a phone
and a desktop pack it'd have to be like
both
you know
but okay let's let's try and open up
this texture and do the lens flare real
quick
oh man this looks awesome
okay let's do a black solid
and we'll go optical flares
and we'll go to options and let's just
find the flare we want i mean
light is a good one because it's natural
hmm
so we want to match that
natural flares here we go
there's so many options andrew kramer
man putting it together
yeah ghoulius i feel you on that man
all right so maybe we do this one but we
just take out all the ridiculous
streaks so
if you guys have never used optical
flares it's a really powerful program
so we can hide all like everything here
that makes up this uh
this lens flare you can check on and off
so
i'm just going to go through here and
uncheck all of the really sharp
bits that make this thing up
and i kind of just want like
hmm
i'm still undecided on the one i want
too
maybe this one let's see what this does
so i'm just gonna set this to
uh to screen
we'll put it right in here
and something like something like that
would be nice
but it's not the right kind of lens
flare
we want something else so
maybe there's some oh this one's maybe
not bad
uh yeah these are all just too intense i
know for a fact we'll definitely need to
like
bring down the intensity on these this
one is subtle
but i feel like the colors aren't right
so we can change the color here to more
of like a
that tungsten greenish
and then we could
take this glow and bring
the brightness down
but this purple is killing me right in
here
so maybe we just lose that bit
but that doesn't look right it just
doesn't look right i feel like
having real lens flares would be the
best way to go
i don't really know of any online
so if you guys know of any like lens
flare packs let me know i'll look into
it this one is subtle
so maybe we just get rid of the really
intense bits that make this up
all right that's not bad i think i like
that it's
it's subtle
and maybe what we can do is just
take any sort of large glow out
so it's just yeah just that bit right
there
and i'll change the color to more of
like a greenish yeah very subtle
awesome um let's check
oh let's add our vignette real quick so
i'll make a new black solid i'm gonna
hit ctrl y
and if you double click the ellipse tool
it'll just make a perfect ellipse
set it to subtract f
for feather ctrl shift h to hide the
mask
and we'll just feather this out about
like there
and we'll set this to overlay
and drop the opacity something like
that feels right maybe work the feather
a little bit more
that looks legit
awesome
back in cinema let's see if our render
kicked out
not that big of a difference honestly
it's not even worth updating
um so you guys will see next week in
unreal engine how easy it is to get this
volumetric fog going and i do want to
get some particles going
up against the light post here so we can
see like little
little moths flying around and then i'd
like to hook my phone
up to unreal engine so we could maybe
film a little walk by or film
just like a static scene of of this
little bit that we set up here
and maybe throughout the week again it's
going to be a very busy week for me
but if i have time i might add a bit
more wire detail and stuff
but this has been fun guys i really
appreciate it thank you so much
um i'm glad that you guys are learning
stuff
along with myself i'm learning as i'm
going to that's the whole point of all
this you learn through
doing it and i'll definitely be saving
this and posting this to my instagram so
if you guys don't follow me on instagram
that's underscore punisher underscore
boom right down there and uh
what else yeah guys stick around because
tuesday
um i'm gonna go live on maxon's youtube
channel cinema4d's youtube channel
if you go to i think 3dmotionshow.com or
maxon.net
you guys will be able to follow the link
and you'll see me live
on tuesday at 9 a.m pacific standard
time breaking down my entire photo
realism
um compositing workflow so when you
shoot your footage and you want to put
real stuff into it
i'm breaking down that whole thing it's
only a 55 minute
stream and then i'm doing a live q a
with matthias
afterwards for about 30 minutes so
definitely do not miss that
and i will upload that to my youtube
channel about a week
after it goes live okay so probably next
next tuesday
and same day on that tuesday all right
that's we're talking tuesday
uh 21st a few days from now
i'm posting the custom hdri tutorial
walking you guys through how to create
your own custom hdris
and at the end of that i'll be selling a
uh a custom hdri pack that i put
together
and it's themed in like the warzone
battlefield style where it's like all
post-apocalyptic and stuff
we got hdris in you know crashed
helicopters crashed airplanes
the middle east kind of style we got
military trucks and all that
in the sewers all that good stuff so i
try to get a unique twist on the hdri
packs because there's a million out
online but it's more just the way if you
guys want to
help support the cause here and and
and support more videos like custom hdri
tutorial or
more streams like this i think i'm just
gonna drop it for like
like eight bucks or something um you
guys can pick that up if you
if you'd like but uh i appreciate you
all
visual you rock man uh thank you for the
super chat
he says thanks for doing all this uh
it's been an incredibly hard time for me
besides
cobin 19 and these weekly challenges are
so awesome
um uh the community is unmatched keep it
up
dude i am really really glad that this
is helping out
it's so much fun um and
and i hope it will continue to be in the
future i know it will be in the future
so
keep it up hang in there guys stay safe
stay healthy
get outside go for a walk or something
and i'll see you guys
on tuesday on the uh what is it
it's either maxon's youtube channel or
cinema4d's youtube channel
tuesday at 9 00 a.m uh pacific standard
time
i'll post the link in the announcements
on the discord channel so don't miss
that let's
frickin fill up that live stream let's
take it by storm
um i've talked too much at this point so
i'm gonna leave but i appreciate you
guys thank you so much
i'll catch y'all later peace have a good
one
i can't end the stream because my mouse
is broken
i straight up can't click what's going
on
what's up guys
wow something is
ctrl i'll delete
okay bye